projet phare c'est le développement de
fermes déception aquacole ronchi cole
élevage de l'ambient élevage de la ghost
afin de permettre aux jeunes du vauclin
de retrouver espoir il retrouvé de
l'emploi dans leur commune en martinique
et s'ils veulent être participé à la
version de la spirale de l'exode de la
jeunesse personne ne peut dire qu'il a
gagné la guerre côté ça agace ou vos
clés on s'est beaucoup employé avec une
chantier d'insertion dans quelques
jeunes qui régulièrement sont sur les
planches du vauclin au bourg paul à
essayer de juguler le phénomène
c'est pas facile surtout que nous sommes
un peu ma seule n'est pas assez aidé à
mon avis mais en tout cas nous avons
approché le barrage très innovant au
vauclin avec un jeune marin pêcheur 13
et mieux et la preuve là vous verrez que
ce barrage va bientôt ouvrir 650 m
on a eu la haute et récemment